water because that one's a little bit more manly fragrance almost and clean yeah clean fresh yeah
love it good job men like it better than tropical seltzer yes absolutely love the fragrance by the
way it's awesome wow wow wow wow i mean this is just absolutely amazing just with i mean all of
the facts that you've given us the sample to be able to smell it i mean and i absolutely love the
the fact that you were really pushing, like, this is a sunless hand primer, it's pH balancing,
it has shave minimizers in it. And now one thing, and I know you had said it, but can
you remind me quick, what age range did you have for this product?
So we did 16 and up, and the reason being is, obviously, young adolescent now, with
the pressure of social media, everyone wants to look good, feel good. The reason that we
didn't go younger is because 16 and up is your demographic, that they are employed.
You know, most of these people's parents, they don't want to pay for their kids' added extra stuff outside of Sephora, right?
So it's also a reasonable price for them to justify it at their age, right?
So I think it helps to broaden our demographic.
And although they cannot UV tan, we can encourage the younger ones in for, like, you know, sunless tanning.
And it kind of correlates with our launch time.
We're thinking May to June, the reason being you're coming into the time of year.
People want to feel good, look good.
Everyone's going out.
like yeah and then one last question quick is this a daily use product I
would say yes and no I think it would depend like if you're using it strictly
for bursa I think you probably want to stay a little bit away from it or spray
tans in general just because there could be the possibility that I could strip it
a little bit faster but I think that the ingredients we have that it is more of
like the moisturization cooling and calming on the skin yeah great answer hey ladies uh i think
you guys absolutely 100 nailed the thing just well practiced well rehearsed all the supportive
materials with it certainly in the sample i don't have a lot to add other than this fragrance if my
wife had this i don't know well let's just leave it i wish you really did so i have right so you
and all that, like, just leave that alone.
Anyway, moving on.
I was so scared
where you were going with that.
I absolutely
love the pitch. You guys, I would have felt like
I was low-key on Shark Tank for a second
when you guys reversed it, and we're saying it
together at the end, because sometimes they do that
on there. Everything to me
was perfect. I love the fragrance. I definitely
could see this being something that I use
just because
I like the fragrance. I like,
obviously I'm going to use body wash. I always use something that's like pH balancing. It's going
to keep my color lasting a lot longer. So with that being said, I also do shower like two or
three times a day. Would you ever consider doing like a bigger bottle size? I think that there
is definitely the option for it. And I think that there's even the option to expand further,
find a moisturizer that can complement it, right? Like I think there's a large
feel that you could take this into once you get the heels turning. So yeah, absolutely. I use a
It's a lot of body wash, that's why I wanted to do it.
All right, good job.
Thank you ladies.
I know it's a long time to stand.
I thank you so much for giving all of your attention
to our last presenters, please.
We gotta court judges.
We're getting that part.
I should be fired.
Mikayla, you got a number for me?
And mole.
Gina, a 91 from Jess, 92 from Nick.
A ninety what?
Five.
Ninety-five.
Absolutely. Okay we'll try. Okay have you ever thought about maybe simplifying the
tanning routine for our clients so they can tan smarter and glow longer? We would
like to introduce Duology. It's the first of its kind dual chamber tanning
solution designed for the complete indoor tanning skincare routine. This
innovative two-in-one system delivers both an indoor tanning solution and a
hydrating tan extender in one sleek ergonomically designed bottle we truly believe that the options
for this bottle are endless we've started with just an intense fire on stage one and a tan
extender on stage two but this really could go as far as doing a tingle on side one and a facial on
side two an intensifier on side one and a bronzer on side two the options are literally endless and
we think this would be amazing to give to our clients they're going for your material skills
Who's got the first questions? Gina.
Hello?
Sorry, my bad.
Hello? Hey Gina.
Okay, I love the versatility, I love the dual.
Like this to me is just,
it screams amazing.
So now when you have bronzer on the left side,
is this going to be an instant natural bronzer,
a dual bronzer,
or what's like
what we got?
So with this one that we gave you specifically,
Specifically, it's just an intense fire and a tan extender because we were going very simple with it.
But if we're talking about bronzer, you could do whatever.
You could do an intense fire on one side and a natural bronzer.
You could do delayed and natural.
We are always telling our clients how important it is to have multiple products in their routine.
This is a great way to introduce that to them in a simplified way without throwing a thousand bottles at them.
So the only negative thing I would say is maybe do this brown just a little bit lighter.
So when you do pop out with that, like, dual-use bronzer, you can richen it up.
But absolutely amazing, like, wow.
Thanks, Gina.
Definitely a cool innovation.
Love the name. The name is fantastic.
It's just very, very original in name.
I would challenge you on the price.
I think you really under-evaluated at 75 Canadian.
This is two six-and-a-half-ounce products, really, if you look at it.
And I think you're way lower than you should be with the name, the story.
And I agree, this is an entire line in the making.
We've got body wash and scrub.
You've got face and body.
You've got no bronzer or bronzer.
I mean, there's so many different things you can do with this.
Talk to me a little bit about the bottle itself.
Is it heavy?
How does it feel in my hand?
Because, of course, it's got a channel cavity in the middle to separate.
So just talk to me, my ownership when I'm holding it.
Because when we're at the salon, we always like to put the product in their hand because that's ownership, right?
So tell me about that.
I think I can answer that one.
So I think the general width of that bottle would be kind of like a tan extender bottle, you know, about four inches wide in that regard, with that sleek ergonomic design.
That way it fits in the hand.
Now, obviously, the challenge of splitting that bottle down the middle, that would be up to our wonderful manufacturers to figure out in that regard.
very but I think it's a it wouldn't be any wider than a haemorrhagia bottle as
an example to be honest with you with that gerbs toe invocations bottle like it you
would be able to kind of sleek it down so yeah I think it would be the best bet
very good first off I love this concept because I feel like it simplifies you guys said that word and I love that great buzz word and I feel like like you said the combinations are endless you know you can I can even see like a body wash with the
the shaving moisturizer as well.
You could do a facial lotion with like a primer.
So again, possibilities are endless.
So in terms of like the creativity for this bottle,
very, very cool.
And again, simplifies it for your customer and your consumer.
Couple questions, but first and foremost,
I noticed the fragrance,
is the fragrance the same in both products?
Do you envision it being in the same fragrance?
And talk a little bit about that fragrance.
I mean, in this particular one,
we're going with that coconut vanilla musk
um as sort of the buzzword for that fragrance you're going for a very unisex um gender
fragrance right because it with the must scent coupled with the vanilla it's a very like luscious
vibe um with a little bit of a coconut water blended in there like it could just be very
neutral across the board whether or not it's the same scent yeah and is the base the same
Sorry, I'll let you answer that question for her too, but then the other thing is, is the base the same, like what are the key hero kind of calls in that base?
Because obviously it sounds like it's a kind of collection, you're a bit envisioning.
We went like first on the fragrance, when we were thinking about uniform sex fragrance, one of the clients that came to mind I was thinking about,
typically are male clients who, I don't use lotion, I don't use product, I don't like to put this on my skin, why are you handing me five bottles I now need to put on?
so without one it was simplifying it so I thought having a unisex fragrance was
better for them in this one I would do both the same fragrance I find if you
talk to some people they love having their lotion in their body spray be the
same fragrance I thought that was key in terms of the base ingredients with this
one again we tried to keep it really simple so we went with just two things
that we love to see in products which was tyrosine and hemp seed oil there to
our hero ingredients that we love to talk about they've been around forever
and there's a reason but I think you could we talked about price point you
could go so far with this where you have like an incredible skincare product in
here with niacinamide and bakuchi oil and you could go crazy and those could
be your hero ingredients in those ones
had two products in one tube with a flip cap on the bottom.
Yeah, and that was like, I don't know, pretty old school,
maybe not as old school as Conjo as earlier,
but I think that, you know, that kind of product design
might fit the product a little bit better,
only because it's just a little easier to use.
A little easier.
You don't have to try to close the pump after you can,
but love the concept, love the fragrance,
love the target demographic, and then it does.
I was literally gonna say the same thing as Nick.
If I'd never been the same, I would've wrote that down.
I think everything was great.
I also personally am like work for a lotion manufacturer. I'm a lazy lotion user. Okay, I like quick
I like easy especially like, you know, just run downstairs and tan, run back upstairs. So I like that idea
I was just gonna say the pumps
I know not necessarily guys come in with like a purse a lot of ladies come in with like a tanning bag
And I just worry about like the pump kind of like getting all over the bag or something
But it's not absolutely everybody's like problem
But just something you can consider with like a different type of pump
But I really like the idea of two, because people like easy, and I always, when I do sales trainings, I always make things easier for people, because that's how you sell.
That's why it says step one, tan, step two, extend.
Great job, y'all.
Thank you.
98 from Gina, and 87 from Nick, from Michaela.
It's almost like these judges are talking at their tables.
All right, one more time, a huge, huge round of applause for all of our presenters.
I, you know, I've been doing this for a long time, Elaine's been doing this for a long time, all of these judges, you know, sometimes we all take it for granted what it takes to get up and talk in front of people, and not everyone has that skill, so we, they're already winners today, just the simple fact that they went through the process, they came up with an idea, and they shared it with you all.
So, I'm actually going to invite Alice and Chelsea back up for a moment, please.
If you guys can take your spot back.
We had some, all of us followed like secret shopper judges now today.
Because if you recall, we did ask you, and you guys seriously brought it.
For this theme today, Canada theme, look at the red, the denim.
You guys all look absolutely, 1000% amazing.
Thank you very much.
So you guys brought your creativity, your strategy and a whole lot of passion to the
table and we really, really appreciate you doing that.
to our judges thank you so much for lending your thought and your ideas and sharing your
experience with our participants today good job good job all right so how are we doing on the
draw tickets okay so do you guys have your draw tickets ready yes all right so while we
time to lay our final pitch scores, we're going to do our draws.
Okay, so the way this is going to work, Crystal tells me, is I'm going to read out the ticket
number and we need a record of you if you have won so if you wouldn't mind
maybe popping upstairs to actually please no no okay all we need is your
salon name apparently you just call her at me your salon name as these Americans
would say just call at me you can write it down to please leave we'll have a
So we're starting with our Australian Gold 2025 Intro Kit. I have a yellow ticket, yellow and white coupon. The number I have is 57912837. Once again, yellow and white coupon, 57...
Our Swedish Beauty Vinyl Intro Kit, I have a blue and white coupon, blue and white, blue
and white, alright, red numbering on the side, 0720841, and what's the one?
Midnight Sun. Congratulations. Designer Skin 2025 Intro Kit. I have a red and white coupon with black numbering on the bottom. Red and white coupon. The number I have is 5802-3562. I'll read it again. Red and white coupon. 5802-3562.
6-2. We got one. What salon? Dark Desire. Congratulations. Corny Tan. I have a blue and white Admit One coupon with blue line written on the bottom. Black numbers on the side. Blue and white coupon. Admit One. The number is 6059-1.
one. And what salon are you from? Purity. Congratulations. Next up, we've got a Devoted
Creation 2025 Color Rush Kit. I've got a blue and black coupon. Admit one. A blue and black
coupon. The number on the bottom is 4419501. We got one. Rays by Rays. Congratulations.
Congratulations. Next one is we've got a Hemp's Botanical Sunshine gift bag. I've got a yellow and white ticket. Yellow and white ticket. This is a Hemp's Botanical Sunshine gift bag from our friends at Sunny.
5, 7, 9, 1, 2, 8, 3, 1.
All right.
Apparently, candy is an advantage, guys.
Oh, eye candy?
All right.
Eye candy.
Congratulations.
Apparently, I need glasses for my ears, too, guys.
I've got a Hemp's Hydro Whip Maximizer Bag Deal up for grabs next.
This is a white and blue coupon that's a blue line on the bottom.
and zero sorry never mind starting again six zero five nine one nine three six yeah awesome
what's him on tanlicious congratulations next we have a pro tan end game bag deal i've got another
yellow and white coupon yellow and white with the black letters on the bottom or sorry black
numbers on the bottom. Five seven nine one. Two seven five
nine. Five seven nine one. Two seven five nine. Yellow and
white. Somebody have one? They did a good job. Prize up for
grab. Interesting. Three twenty twenty-five boss lady intro
kit. I've got a blue and white ticket. The numbers on the
the side are 9194-290. 9194-290. 9194-290. Yay! Where do you want me from? Sorry? Lake?
Okay. Devoted Creations kit. I've got a red and white ticket this time. Red and white
ticket five eight zero four four one five eight zero two three four four one
got one awesome what's your salon name congratulations the next is a good one
we got a $250 gas card up for grabs we have a yellow and white ticket yellow and white ticket for this gas card
5, 7, 9, 1, 4, 2, 5, 7, 9, 1, which one, London, do you know your number, 113, congratulations,
next we have a $250 gift card for Aritzia, a red and white ticket guys, red and white
I know, you're like, I've got to go back.
58023625.
This is a red and white ticket.
580225.
That's me.
Anyone going once?
I'll take it.
No one wants it.
We're going to split it.
Right?
The judges want it.
They're the donators.
They want it.
Thank you so much to all of our vendors who donated these prizes.
I will. It's a red and white ticket. It's 5-8-0-2-3-6-2-5. You got it? Nice. What's the
line you from? Sol Exotica. Which one? Ancaster? So, glow system. I've got a blue and white
ticket for this guy. Blue and white ticket. Looks like we've got three Norval glow systems
to give away. So this is our first one.
6-0-5
9-0-7-2
Blue and white ticket.
What's the last again?
6-0-5
9-0-7-2
Going once, going twice.
Alright, we're going to pause that one
and carry on with the next.
Pause.
This is also for a Norvell Glow System. I've got a red and white ticket this time.
Red and white ticket, 5-0...never mind.
Numbers are starting to blend together, guys, even though I'm wearing my glasses.
Okay, red and white ticket, 5-8-0-6-4-9.
5-8-0-2-3-6-4-9, red and white ticket.
Norvell Glow Systems are hard to give away. I'll take it. Red and White Ticket, 580, 649.
Alright, hold please. Glow Systems. Oh, we got one. So that was 649.
Soul Exotica. Soul Exotica, which one? Ancaster. Ancaster.
Yellow and White Ticket. Yellow and White Ticket. This is another Norvell Glow System.
5-7-9-1-6-9-5, 5-7-9-1-6-9-5, looking for 2-6-9-5 on the yellow ticket, okay, passed it, congratulations, this is, okay, so we're back on the Norval Blow system, we didn't have a winner on the first ticket, so we've drawn another one, so this is Norval Blow, sorry, blue and black ticket,
The blue and black ticket is 441-9524.
441-9524.
Oh, we got one.
What salon are you from?
Babitan 152.
Pass that ticket over for her to Emily for me, please.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations.
All right.
Now these super cute little beavers up here from Slotay.
We've got one to give away as well for you guys.
Are you talking at the end?
Yeah, I'm going to say that.
I'll give you some good content.
All right, I'll try my best.
Blue and white ticket, 9194-308.
9194-308.
That's $75.
You got one?
Okay.
We've got credit with an Embrace the Sun book.
We've got two of these to give away.
Yellow and white ticket.
Yellow and white ticket, guys.
5791-873.
5-7-9-1-2-8-7-3
for a smart tan ticket and embrace the sun book.
Excellent.
I think the books are behind the counter.
Oh, they're over there.
Okay.
If you want to just bring that up to Emily for me,
thank you.
Congratulations.
What salon are you from?
Peskany Studio.
Another yellow and white ticket
for another smart tan credit
and embrace the sun book.
Yellow and white ticket.
5-7-9-1-2-6-3-9
5, 7, 9, 1, 2, 6, 3, 9, yellow ticket.